rg vous souvenez son père a disparu
tintin n'est plus et pourtant il fait
encore parler de lui à travers un
ouvrage que lui a consacré un chercheur
belge qui nous propose de découvrir la
face cachée du héros de notre jeunesse
une enquête de michel perron le 3 mars
dernier
hergé disparaissait à l'âge de 76 ans sa
mort mais tu es bien sûr un terme aux
aventures de celui qui l'a rendu célèbre
tintin le personnage n'en demeure pas
moins toujours aussi vivant auprès de
ses lecteurs
quel que soit leur âge où je parle déjà
depuis y est depuis depuis le but d'être
dit toujours aimer tentant ainsi si un
autre album qui a fait au total je
dirais qu est-ce qui vous recherchez
quand vous quand vous lisez les albums
de tintin laventure l'avant tire le
voyage des voyages avons nous eu aussi
le rayon son bain je crois que c'est le
faite vous fait qu'ils aillent un peu
partout que puis qu'il arrive toujours à
triompher alors que finalement il ya
plein de quoi mes parents dans mon père
il est toujours content quand je
cherchais l'ecofin qishan 30 je suis pas
et attend pour moi ça ne fera que je
vois un enfant qui lie archers qui
trouve quelque chose que qui le fait
rêver un adulte qui qui les rg qui
trouve autre chose et moi qui relie les
albums pour la 30e la 40e 3 chaque fois
je continue à découvrir de nouveaux
détails de nouvelles choses qui me qui
me passionne chaque fois je marche à
nouveau dans l'histoire
passionné par l'oeuvre du dessinateur
benoît pts a mis deux ans à rassembler
les nombreux travaux d'hergé encore
inconnu du public
je suis rendu compte qu'il existait tout
une partie de cette oeuvre qui était
inconnu terre qu'à côté des albums tête
et merveilleux albums des aventures de
tintin ou même des
autre aventure de joseph de cliquer plus
qu il existait tout un travail d'hergé
des pages qui avait été coupée de ses
albums parce que l'on soit pas y avait
62 pages seulement
donc tout ce qui dépassait devait
supprimer il y avait des couvertures
qu'il avait fait des centaines de
couvertures dans les années 30 il ya des
dessins publicitaires il ya des
illustrations de livres
enfin bon toute une série de choses
connu un tout petit peu ou via même
complètement oublié qu'ils méritaient
d'être montrées on voit par exemple
comment hergé transforme une histoire
vont mal il ya une histoire
bon comme l'île noire qui l'a fait
d'abord en noir et blanc puis la mise en
couleur quelques années plus tard et
puis il trouvait que cette histoire
était devenu un peu vieillotte un peu
anciennes par certains côtés il a
complètement redessiné en changeant les
décors les voitures etc
on sent certainement que le style
d'hergé se forge petit à petit à partir
de quelque chose de très informe d'avoir
un le dessin dans tintin chez les
soviets c'est encore très très maladroit
très très très beau et puis il ya toute
une série d' influence qui vont qui vont
traverser rg entre autres influences art
déco dans les années dans les années 30
on le verra très marquée par un style
graphique qui a par imprudence et
publicitaire dos publicité et ensuite et
bien hergé d'inventer son style ce
fameux style qu'on appelle maintenant la
ligne claire qui est le style qui
cherchent une efficacité maximale une
simplicité très très grande pour que
chaque image raconte véritablement
quelque chose pour que chaque image
fasse passer une information de la
manière la plus évidente
vous pensez que c'est le disney européen
c'est mieux que ça encore mieux en tout
cas tintin était vraiment notre héros